So now we're going to turn to the parallel reduce.
So how do we formulate an algorithm, a procedure to be able to speed this up by running in parallel?
Let's take a look at this reduce picture here.
At first glance this seems very difficult to parallelize.
Note that every operation is dependent on the result of the previous operation.
So let's write these operations explicitly.
When we formulate the reduction in this way, we have no parallelism.
So can you figure out how to rewrite this to expose more parallelism
so that we can do more than 1 thing at the same time?
And the hint is, use the associative property of the operator.
How do you rewrite a + b, take the result, add it to c, take the result. add it to d,
to allow parallel execution?
In your answer please use parentheses to show grouping.